what car does Michael Jackson belong on
like a Pontiac or something a Lotus um
that's classic yeah old school Lotus
Michael Jackson well because I'm trying
to picture it because it's a dope idea
or a short bus or a short bus or just an
all-white van
[Music]
all right so uh there's this woman from
Miami
who got her head shots taken headshots
headshots I'm just making sure that the
live is on because we're all live and
only our patreon people can see behind
the scenes live but go ahead just
letting them know let them know let them
know there's this Miami woman who got
her headshots taken and then the photos
were sold to a stock photo site and now
she's on the cover of an erotic novel
titled his big childhood sweetheart
I got the whole story mixed up because
it sounded juicy and then it sounded
boring
okay say the whole story so
I'm supposed to be the one at 80 to 8080
but I was paying attention oh my God in
the middle of saying that that's a
terrible picture so I already know what
you said so this lady right here
she just wanted to go get some head
shots one day from a photographer she
hired this photographer for 100 bucks
100 bucks all right but she didn't read
the fine print on what he was gonna do
with these photos and he sold it to a
stock photo site and she didn't realize
until some of her people in her friend's
Circle sent her photos of her being on
the cover of an erotic child or not
child sorry what it says the big
childhood sweetheart childhood
sweetheart the word was in there why is
that embarrassing she's winning the guy
of her dream no I think the money right
what did the photographer make off
something like that he probably just
sold it as a buyout right the fact that
she ain't gonna make none of it though
she she paid she paid him 100 to take
headshot photos of her but then he got
he ducked out he cashed out by selling
it to a stock photo spot no water was so
cheap it's a side note and maybe it's
because I feel like I'm getting old but
a lot of like lady friends and my age uh
read those books yeah and I didn't know
that was a thing me neither oh even
younger girls by reading Danielle's it's
Daniel Steele man yeah I didn't know it
was a thing what is that motion just so
you can explain to the fans like DJ
stuff
they play with fidget Spinners in their
pants they're definitely fidgeting while
they're reading I think yeah I didn't
know it was like that they're getting
hot I thought that was a joke oh really
yeah I thought that was you know what I
mean like what's his name Fabio yeah I
thought that was all like a kind of a
joke it was like a satire but they're in
that [__] huh I mean it it gets pretty
erotic oh you read them you'll be just
the chapters have you read one
I've looked at the chapters or some of
that [__] and they're steamy yeah I read
it as a kid it should be reasonable
we'll talk about like like his his hair
was as thick as Mane and then like his
his shirt was like flapping in the wind
and I remember being a little kid going
[Laughter]
he was shirtless on a horse embarked
like ooh it's very situational too huh
because you never use other you never
hear other people using words like that
you know what I mean like I'm reading
[__] like I don't know like X-Men or
some [__] or like some Truck magazine
and it's very factual and then we did
the motor swap and now it's a 4x4
and then I'm like okay that's regular
English and then you read that one
you're like whoa whoa it's crazy
swapping a motor it suddenly it's a four
by four
something went wrong here
I mean that's what like 50 Shades of
Gray was right yeah see yeah did you
read that no I didn't read that but I
heard when I you know the second it got
super popular and then you realize that
all the girls that you know have read
that you're like you know what wait a
minute I [__] up in my youth because
I'm realizing now the best ways to get
girls was actually do the things that
they like
like what
yeah but the downside is you're doing
boring [__] it's the downside no okay so
like so like you want to get girls doing
guy [__] right like you think when
you're young you like cars so you want
to attract Girls by getting a car oh
cool you like muscles so you think like
girls would well maybe they do but do
you know
but they're like but then but then like
the real [__] is just you should read
these novels yeah if they're fantasizing
about that be the man in the novels
that's true it took me that long to
[__] realize you tell me Megan Fox
and Transformers ain't real just a
hottie well I mean she was at Pete
Davidson yeah but she's like fixing the
car and the sweat's coming down but
they're rare though most chicks aren't
like that she's single though right yeah
do you think she watched JK do you think
Megan no she's like hold on
Cheers yeah I think so she's with Kodak
Black I think she's with Kodak Black now
is he all there in the head I think no
what's the quote that's going crazy
right now is he scatterbrained my name
Kodak Black but when you see me I'm
white
have you seen that interview so good
it's wild it's so funny I don't know if
he's doing a bit or if he's just like a
like a kind of like Spacey I don't think
it's a bit oh yeah it's he's definitely
not writing these novels he doesn't have
that vocab he does not have that he's
very tangential dude you should see the
interview with him and Caleb Presley
he's like all over what happens if
you're like oh I should be like the guy
in the novel but the guy in the novel is
a car loving Buff Ass
then it works but is it isn't even like
50 Shades of Gray I don't remember what
that story is you're like a billionaire
I didn't even watch the movie aren't
they like low-key [__] you know what
I mean no I think they're like a
billionaire that uh Sexes her yeah
by men
he's like I should have just been a
billionaire he ties her up and stuff I
also think chicks are just dumb though I
think like they want they want hit him
hit him tell me how you really feel you
know what dudes they want things in
these books right but if that dude was
right in front of her face she wouldn't
be able to see and what a friend zone
then yeah your face is stuck in a book
that's true dude that's true dog stop
friend zoning us we're gonna start
reading more books oh you know what is
crazy uh do you remember that girl linty
Nguyen uh-huh she got her photo taken
and uh it got sold to Scientology and
they use her face on the Scientology
building the billboard yeah the one
that's right in front of the Hollywood
one yeah and it says it's her face
straight up and she's like oh [__] that
was from like a headshot thing what's
the money on this [__] right cause like
you go home is it homework what's the
store with all the cards yeah homework
you go there and then there's all the
stock photos of families and dogs or
Grandpa and Grandma yeah how do I get in
there with like my golden retriever
there's got to be cash I don't pay you a
lot for that no
because he's like in a conference
meeting or like he's in some stock photo
[__] yeah you don't get paid a lot for
stock photos because it's stock photos
you don't get paid a lot but you pay a
lot to use them when you go to Getty
Images or wire image and you look at the
price of one photo look yourself up and
you'll be like it's like 300 bucks what
yeah but that's like
the keys for that one thing and that's
it you're signing on it just take a
spoon hold the cactus we got to be
getting images that's what we got you
have to be getting him he's not be in it
yet okay so we got to do the same
bracket is this what exactly is Getty
Images because I see that all the time
that's different but that's like that's
more for like uh people that shoot
celebrities on red carpets or go to
events those photos are worth money
because at some point someone might need
that person Paparazzi yeah how's that
but that's free yeah but we're not
talking about celebrity photos we're
talking about like stock footage when
it's like regular ass people that's like
but then you got to be a Paparazzi
nobody wants to be that [__] the
legality of it seems weird right because
Paparazzi can go and snag Bart taking a
[__] in the bush and then I could sell
that but I'm making money off your
likeliness yeah I thought that's illegal
yeah but that's different he's taking a
[__] in a bush like that it's not
illegal you could take a picture of
someone in public oh but if I if he was
in his house taking a [__] and I snapped
one and sold it that's his private and
likeliness I think if it's through the
window I think the reasonable thing is
you can't have taken it from an angle
that was illegal to get to or some [__]
but what about all these pictures of
like celebs like on a yacht right oh
Jeff base was out of shape again but
then he's like on his own [__] in the
ocean I think because you don't own the
ocean you don't own the ocean and he's
Outdoors on that boat have you seen
those lenses they could probably Zoom to
the [__] next ocean but the bird
watching people all right my next one
then so I take a picture of Bart legally
wherever but then I throw him on a shirt
and I sell Bart's face on a shirt that's
illegal right because there's likeliness
and I'm making money off it so like
let's say you go to a basketball game
you take a picture of Jordan playing
yeah no I think it's illegal can you put
on a shirt I'm pretty sure that shit's
illegal if I I say that to all the
Hispanics outside the state or no.com no
everywhere so no so yeah yeah yeah
because everyone it kind of pisses me
off as like a Creator where people are
like just throwing Kobe on a shirt and
I'm like of course you're gonna make
money you're selling Kobe but that's not
cool it's like at the point where it
costs too much money to go after them
they don't do it they're too small fries
but it's technically illegal but but it
probably also only works when there's
like somebody like Kobe's so big that
thousands of people are doing that so
it's like oh also really difficult to
stop but if you're just like you know
[__] JK news and there's one person
out there making money off your merch
like we're gonna go figure out how to
stop them yeah there wasn't
um we had fans who made copies but they
didn't sell it they didn't have enough
time for the shirts to show up to their
house so what they did is they silk
screened the designs and then they
showed up to our show half flattery
halfway that's more flattering yeah but
they actually ordered the shirts but
they didn't it didn't arrive in time oh
you [__] looked up Kendra stuff on
like taobao and Alibaba and stuff you
know what I mean amazing garments yeah
better than the original you know what's
kind of different though it I think
there is a difference between whether
it's the picture or if it's on a shirt
because if you go to a souvenir shop in
Hollywood you can't buy celebrities on
shirts but you can buy actual celebrity
photos on that rack yeah where's the
likeliness like drawn I mean that's the
whole reason Nike signs Jordan so they
own his likeliness his likeness yeah
likeness oh he's like likeliness how
much people like him
all that how about on the mug I I see
celebrity pictures
I like that
there's a difference between if it's a
merchandise item versus this photo I
don't know either and can you hey like
let's say uh a body Shopper like someone
that does custom paint right what if I
want a big [__] Michael Jackson on
the hood of my car I think that's okay
as long as you're not like replicating
it hella times to sell it I think that
might be cool as long as it's not on a
Ferrari that's an Obama Ferrari will sue
you what what card is Michael Jackson
belong on like a Pontiac a Lotus
that's classic yeah old school Lotus
what car does Michael Jackson well cause
I'm trying to picture it because it's a
dope idea or a short bus or a short bus
or just an all-white van
are you listening
that's my
did the lady get any money no right you
can't or she did no she didn't get any
money off it no she paid and then they
stole her [__] yeah that's [__] that's
we gotta read the final well that also
is it sucks too because that book looks
like it's accentuating that she's a
plus-sized person uh it's specifically
on the front page talks about this is a
BBW uh story
yeah like what if that happened to you
and it said like my little railroad
Builder and I'm like damn it dude
yo we should have someone Photoshop all
of us doing doing some kind of romance
novel yeah my little railroad worker my
little gold miner or you know like you
know like School textbooks use the [__]
out of stock photos what if there was
one about the Opium [__] crisis it
had you just like sad looking there is
something about education that uh all
those laws don't count if you're
teaching with it because my mom was a
teacher all that [__] don't count so my
mom my mom could like straight steal
like documentaries and show them in
that's true Nick the little railroad
worker
dude Ryan was able to take one photo of
naked Jiu Jitsu class and then put that
in the 70 different like versions this
is gonna go too crazy that picture of me
in that class was so crazy dude it was
so funny that was mostly other people
and everyone's like add-ons to it was
like was the best because you look so
like upset and I wasn't trying to I
swear I was like just take the picture
[Music]
foreign